there's a weird story that caught my eye
recently this Ohio man apparently who
has a farm who I'm I'm I'm sorry it
looks like some of the audience has a
question yes sir yeah hi it this is so
weird I'm sorry to bother you but do you
do you see my shirt yeah I see your
shirt yeah it's a hand squirting like a
mustard bottle yeah right so on the way
in I saw another guy in your audience
who like I don't know it seems like he
has the other half of the shirt is there
waiting is there a way to get a shot of
him he's sitting right over there I
don't see him I was thinking the same
thing that's so weird it's like we're
two parts of the same story yeah oh
that's so that's very cool do you guys
you know each other or something no but
I'd like to know him I mean we we
clearly both love hot dogs yes and it's
not just this shirt if you seem like a
great guy
so do you man thanks man I I think we
totally hit it off you know buddy I
think we are hitting it off okay guys I
love the shirts are great but if you
don't mind we're gonna just move on with
the show okay thank you as I was saying
this story the news caught my eye in
Ohio this guy has a farm what sorry but
I don't want this to end I got a know
that guy we were meant to be friends
that's what I was gonna say can we can
we just sit together we have so many hot
dog related things to discuss please mr.
Conan
shirred okay fine
just sit together sit together I got a
show to do please do you mind thank you
all right okay back to what I was saying
okay
in Ohio okay there's this guy and he had
a farm and the weird thing is he got
this idea that he was gonna rob a bank
and he wanted to pay for his engagement
ring so well we couldn't agree more
Nigel and you know what we're very
excited to be working with you as well
yeah it's been a passion project of ours
for years talk to you soon
what are you guys doing what are you
doing you're not gonna believe this
we just pitched the documentary about
hot dogs to the BBC and they bought it
they bought it
oh stop guys stop
No now that's that's stupid the BBC just
would never buy a documentary there's
this notion that the only hotdogs that
exists are these factory made creations
these artificial tubes that we see in
plastic wrapping but that's just not
true
there is a place though it sounds like
legend or the imaginings of a child
where hot dogs real hot dogs have
created organic and natural in a
sustainable environment from the earth
food
here we go here we go here look at that
nice a foursome like there are less I
suppose of a foot long so much for now
you see here almost a half dozen right
there
this forest alone contains over 97
different varieties of dogs with new
species being discovered every year it
is done this is where cocktail weenies
come from they grow right the ground
like pearl onions
sadly due to deforestation this is one
of the last remaining natural
frankfurter groves on the planet but
against all odds the dogs continue to
flourish the only two square miles it
produces over 25 tons of wieners per
year oh my god but the main benefit of a
trip to weena Woods you're no longer in
that studio in Burbank and that's how
you get out in taping
you
you